[Music]
today for our daily cancellation
we go on a journey and we'll no doubt
find many people to cancel along the way
it starts
right where i most want to be up in the
sky with the unidentified aerial
phenomena otherwise known as ufos
the headlines that we've seen regarding
this subject over the past 12 hours have
been seemingly designed
to cause me emotional trauma speaking of
trauma
here's the new york times headline quote
government report finds no evidence ufos
were alien spacecraft
i'm starting to feel some ptsd many
other headlines making the same
declaration now
i want to read a little bit of this
times article to you and
and please note how the headline is
supposedly that there's no evidence of
aliens
but the real news to me is quite a bit
different here's what it says
american intelligence officials have
found no evidence that aerial phenomena
witnessed by navy pilots in recent years
are alien spacecraft
but they still cannot explain the
unusual movements that have mystified
scientists and the military
according to senior administration
officials briefed on the findings of a
highly anticipated government report
the report determines that the vast
majority of more than 120 incidents over
the past two decades did not originate
from any american military or other
advanced u.s government technology
that determination would appear to
eliminate the possibility that navy
pilots who reported seeing unexplained
aircraft
might have encountered programs the
government meant to keep secret but
that's about the only conclusive finding
in the classified intelligence report
and while forthcoming unclassified
version expected to be released to
congress by june 25th
will present a few other firm
conclusions or rather few other firm
conclusions
senior officials briefed on the
intelligence conceded
that the very ambiguity of the findings
meant the government could not
definitively rule out theories that the
phenomenon
observed by military pilots might be
alien spacecraft
okay so what's the real headline here it
seems to me the headline is
that this technology definitely is not
our own
our government has no idea where it's
from and they can't rule out the
possibility that it originates from a
different solar system
so okay so no the headline is they've
ruled out
one explanation and they didn't rule out
the alien explanation
so we had a few possible explanations
for this
i don't know three or four one of them
is now gone and it's not
the alien one is still on the table
we're still alive
alien believers we're still in business
now call me crazy but
the government can't rule out
possibility that mysterious foreign
technology is from outer space
is bigger news than the government has
no direct evidence of aliens
now both are true of course but the
former headline seems to capture the
news a little bit better in my opinion
now i don't want to focus today on the
alien hypothesis only i've focused on
that plenty i'll continue to give
uh top give to provide top-notch alien
content to you in the future
as we await the report which by the way
i did realize a couple days ago to my
horror that um
if this report comes out on on june 25th
i'm not gonna be here i'm going on
vacation at the end of the month
and i'll be gone for you know like eight
or nine days
it'll be just my luck if the damn report
comes out
like on the first day of my vacation
because you know if i'm here and the
report comes out we're doing a week on
aliens
oh yes it's happening
that'll be just my luck you know what's
gonna we're gonna i'm gonna go on
vacation the alien report comes out
and i'm gonna have to say to my wife
listen i gotta go
i have something i need to do and i'm
going to drive back here
and leave her wherever we are so we can
talk about aliens i'm sure she'll
understand
remember like i told you my wife is a
big believer in aliens
wink wink now uh anyway for now though
just for the sake of argument i want to
i want to take into consideration
let's just take into consideration this
idea that uh putting aliens aside
that the flying objects may have more
earthly origins so going back to the
times article this is what they say
about that
intelligence officials believe that at
least some of the aerial phenomena could
be experimental technology from a rival
power most likely russia or china
one senior official briefed on the
intelligence said without hesitation the
u.s officials knew it was not american
technology
he said there was more there was worry
among intelligence and military
officials that china or russia could be
experimenting with hypersonic technology
russia has been investing heavily in
hypersonics believing the technology
offers the ability to evade
american missile defense technology
china has also developed hypersonic
weaponry and included it in military
parades
if the phenomena were chinese or russian
aircraft officials said it would suggest
that two powers
hypersonic research has far outpaced
american military development
now as much as i hate to admit it it
does seem that the
china-russia theory is the is is is
maybe the more likely more plausible
explanation
okay now that doesn't make the more
entertaining
alien hypothesis implausible
you know at least it the the russia
china thing is the more plausible
explanation for some of the sightings
we should keep in mind that there have
been sightings all over the world
um so this is not just one thing we're
talking about it's not as though every
single ufo has to come from the same
place whether that be a place on earth
or elsewhere
but let's really think about the
possibility that a foreign country
likely an adversary an enemy has
developed military technology
so advanced that our military has to at
least entertain the possibility
that it's not even from this planet
this all seems to create a rather
frightening context
for stories like this from the new york
post
it says quote the pentagon defended the
military's diversity and inclusion
training programs amid a torrent of
criticism
saying they're essential for recruiting
the right people in its duty to defend
the nation pentagon spokesman john kirby
was asked during
tuesday's briefing about gop lawmakers
crafting creating sites urging
whistleblowers
in the armed services to expose
progressive diversity training programs
some of which have reportedly deemed
white people quote inherently evil
so that was the question let's listen
now to john kirby's answer explaining
why the military
needs to focus on diversity and
inclusion and tolerance and equity
and why that makes us safer let's listen
some republican lawmakers have been
attacking various efforts on the
diversity inclusion front in the
military complaining about the stand
down early order earlier this spring
some have started a system on social
media for active duty troops to file
complaints about the so-called
woke media military what is your
observation or comment on that
well these are members of congress
jennifer we respect their uh rights and
their responsibilities we certainly
respect the
the oversight that the congress provides
um
i'm not going to comment on any specific
one initiative that
that members of congress might be doing
i think that's more appropriate for them
to speak to what i can
speak to uh is what we're
really focused on here at the department
and that's defending the nation
um and that means putting in place
uh the right resources uh the right
strategies the right operational
concepts to
to to do that around the world
so diversity and inclusion are essential
to defending our nation he says
and he's indeed accurately communicating
the defense department's operating
principle in fact as the dod affiliated
website military one source explains in
a recent article quote
the diverse makeup of the armed forces
is one of its greatest assets when
service members of different races
ethnicities religions sexual
orientations and other identities
unite for a common mission the result is
a stronger and more effective force to
ensure continued progress
the dod has established the independent
defense advisory committee on diversity
and inclusion in the armed forces
this committee will continue the work of
examining any and all issues that will
improve equal opportunity diversity
and inclusion in the military diverse
and inclusive ranks are essential to
morale
force cohesion and readiness now as
always
there is no attempt to provide evidence
supporting the assertion that a diverse
and inclusive military is more effective
whenever anyone in a position of
authority is put on the spot about this
they always dissemble they obfuscate as
the pentagon spokesman did in the clip
we just played
they start talking about how the
military needs to find the best people
for the job etc
and yeah they do that's the point but
what they don't explain is how the
military finds the most talented and
competent people for the job
by hiring and recruiting based on
something other than
talent and competence if you care more
about
finding the best people then you would
simply recruit and train
the best people whatever they look like
whatever sex they might be if you end up
with a diverse military as a byproduct
of your focus on skill
and competence then great if you let's
say
end up with a military comprised almost
entirely of straight men
that's great too however it shakes out
is fine
because the people you have on board are
the best of the best diversity again
should be a byproduct if anything not
the goal
not a litmus test but that's not how our
military's top brass see it
they're putting out ads featuring
sorority girls with lesbian moms and the
cia is bragging about hiring women with
anxiety disorders
and they're sending military members and
intelligence officers to mandatory
sensitivity training courses and
critical race theory brainwashing
sessions
because they believe that the ultimate
mission of these institutions
is to support progressive social causes
that's what they believe
meanwhile china and russia are finding
the very best and toughest people
that their nations have to offer and
setting them to the task of defending
their country
and expanding their empires and even
potentially
developing technology that looks like
it's from another galaxy
in comparison with that we are
committing an act of national suicide
we're not the first nation to kill
itself but we may be the first to do it
so intentionally
and abruptly and quickly and through
such bizarre
means in short
i would like to once again send out a
plea to the aliens
to take me with you before you leave to
go back to your home planet
because i know eventually you're leaving
because
you got to be sick of this and please
allow my wife and kids to come too
i haven't consulted them about this but
i think they'll adjust and
ultimately they'll thank me for it and
everyone would be better off
as for who i'm canceling well
i guess the pentagon the media for
continuing to doubt the
alien hypothesis just canceling everyone
which is
which is how i like to to end uh every
week on a friday
and we'll leave it there listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated